Let's put D as the header in this column. D for difference. If you figured this
out yourself, great job. We'll put equals A2 minus B2. And there we have our
difference. Then we'll copy this cell, 'cuz we'll copy the formula. Go to cell
C26. Highlight the whole column C, and then paste. And we get all our
differences. Let's calculate the average difference. We get the same thing we
got for our point estimate of the differences. Now let's calculate the standard
deviation of these. So we have each value, minus the mean. So remember we're
subtracting a negative number, and then square it. So these are our squared
deviations from the mean. So we'll sum them up and then divide by n minus 1,
which is 24. Finally, we'll take the square root. We get about 3.69.